て：やぁーどうも東海のてつやだ
は：やぁ、どうもはじめしゃちょーだ
て：バカにしてんな
は：はい
は：はい、皆さん夏の季節といいますと
は：やっぱ虫が多いと思うんです
は：ほら
て：ほら！（驚
は：夏となるとやはり小さいコバエとか
は：虫が凄いじゃま！
は：基本的になんか家で食べ物とか置いてると
は：すぐコバエとかいろんな虫が寄って来て
は：凄い嫌だと思うんですけども
は：そんな、コバエを退治する
は：電撃ラケットという物がございます
は：まぁ、これですね
は：これどんな物かといいますと
は：普通に電源を押すと
（カチッ）
は：こういう感じでランプが光って
は：光っているあいだにここに電撃が走ると
は：電撃がはしｔ～～～（噛んだ）
は：（噛んだ…）
て：（噛んだな…）
は：電撃が走ってる間に
は：こうやって虫をひゅっとすると
は：バリバリっと
て：電気で殺すと
は：いや、退治するんです。
て：表現が良くなかったですね
は：はい
て：失礼しました
は：殺す…って書いてある…（震
て：ｗｗｗ
て：電撃殺虫ラケット～
は：いろんな電撃ラケットがあるじゃぁ、ないですか
は：第1回　電撃利きラケット選手権～
て：どうゆう事ですかこれは～
もう、要するに虫の気持ちにならないと、分からない。
虫に応じでどれを使うかも大事だと思うんですよ。
小回りの利くラケットで攻撃した方が、倒しやすい虫もいると言う・・・
恐いな
で、これ、あの、真似しないでください
使用上・・・危ないので絶対指をいれるな、って書いてあるんですけども、
で、その、どれだけ痛いかとか危ないかって言うのを、今日我々が身を持って
皆さんにお伝えしますので
「こんなことになるよ？」って言う悪い例として観て下さい。
事故の実験映像とかありますもね
ㇵ〰確かにね
事故ると危ないよ～、みたいなね？
悪い例ですから
ここも、ほぼ一緒だけど、ちょっと違う
ちょっと微妙に違う
ここ、３つ残して、
この３つで、ちょっと利き電撃ラケットしいこうと思います
電撃の感度を、先ず・・・
この・・・
し・・・し
しで
試電撃しないとダメだね
試電・・・
試電しないといけないんで
順番に、ちょっと１個ずつ味わっていこうと思います。
はい
先ずは、赤いやつから。
じゃあ・・・
味わっていこう
なんでなんで
じゃんけんで、じゃ負けた
さいしょはグ！じゃんけんポン
ほんとにさ、ダメなんだってやったら
まって、軽くね？先ず
だっていきなりバリン！って来たら俺しんやうぜ？
いいよ、じゃあ、優しくね？
待って
せーの、
まだ大丈夫だヤバい
ほい
あれ？
まあ、まあ、まあ、
ビリビリする、ビリビリする
よいしょ
ヤバい事言いだしたよ、急に
人でやるよりこっちの方が絶対・・・
ね？絶対痛いじゃん
やーーー
こわいよー
でもやっぱり一回やっとかないと、・・・ね？
まあね？
こわい、勝手になったよ、今
一番強いの買えばいいって結論に至っちゃうんで
取りあえず、これの危険性を今日は身を持って
体験して行きましょ
じゃ、指入れますか！
解んない、はい
落ち着きました
はい
意味わかんなくない？これ
急に来るのか、マジで
指出して、指出して
はい
行きます
や、分かんない
勝手にやっちゃった
行きます
はい
スリー、ﾄｩｳ
痛かった？
なんか、あたったなー、ぐらい
痛くないの？
ぜんぜん痛くない
パァを前に出してやる、パアを前に
行きますよ？
はい、はい、
出しました出しました
３・２･１
ほい！
痛いぞ、普通に痛かった、普通に痛かった。痛、イタ
今これ